culture
merci madame la ministre vous voulez
vous exprimer avant qu'on je vous en
prie
juste rapidement je voulais remercier
donc madame la Présidente je voulais
vous remercier je voulais remercier tous
les sénateurs d'avoir
voté ce budget qui est si important pour
nos anciens et pour le sacrifice qu'ils
ont pour la nation merci beaucoup
ma parole est à Monsieur et blé
rapporteur spécial la commission des
finances
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
le montant global des crédits demandés
dans le cadre du présent projet de loi
de finance pour la mission culture
s'élève à plus de 3 milliards 700
millions d'euros soit une progression
dépassant 7%
celle-ci est supérieure à l'hypothèse
d'inflation retenue il y a quelques
semaines pour
2023 en projet de loi de programmation
des finances publiques
laquelle hypothèse devrait cependant
rapidement être remise en cause si l'on
observe le niveau déjà constaté et les
perspectives
d'inflation dans un proche avenir
j'aborderai dans un premier temps le
programme 131 dédié à la création sa
dotation est majorée de 10% pour
dépasser le milliard d'euros cette
progression des crédits peut être en
première analyse saluée dans un contexte
de reprise délicate de l'activité
singulièrement de l'activité culturelle
elle ne laisse cependant pas toutes les
inquiétudes pour l'ensemble du secteur
confronté à un effet de ciseaux entre
redémarrage progressif mais l'an de
l'activité et hausse du coût des
dépenses contraintes notamment bien sûr
énergétiques pour les opérateurs de
l'État c'est sur coûts ne seront pas
intégralement compensés en loi de
finances ce qui devrait induire une
réduction des marges artistiques 30% en
2023 50%
en 2024 la fermeture de certains
opérateurs à la rentrée 2023 est une
hypothèse malheureusement crédible faute
de pouvoir produire certains spectacles
la perspective des Jeux Olympiques est
paralympiques de 2024 constituent
également une source supplémentaire
d'anxiété avec la probabilité renforcée
d'annulation de festival des deux
concerts en raison d'un manque de force
de l'ordre et de société privée pour en
assurer la sécurité je relève en outre
que l'action du ministère dans le
domaine de la création peut apparaître
brouillé la multiplication des objectifs
à signer 16 sous actions pour les
actions 1 et 2 et le recours soutenu à
la labellisation fragilise en effet sa
lisibilité
j'observe par ailleurs le caractère
résiduel pour ne pas dire marginal
qu'elle peut revêtir dans les
territoires où elle se résume à un
financement complémentaire des
politiques territoriales
pour conclure sur ce programme je
m'attarderai sur deux mesures la
première vise la poursuite du programme
de commande publique monde nouveau mise
en place dans le cadre du plan de
relance 10 millions d'euros seront
dédiés à ce dispositif qui vise
notamment à faire entrer la culture dans
des zones où elle n'est plus assez
présente espace ruraux périphérie
urbaine ou coeur de ville dégradée il
conviendra cependant d'être vigilant sur
la réalité de l'accompagnement des
artistes la complémentarité avec le 1%
culture et le droit de suite que le
ministère doit avoir sur les œuvres
ainsi financées s'agissant notamment des
arts visuels
deuxième mesure les 12,7 millions
d'euros qui viennent abonder le soutien
à l'emploi dont 7 millions d'euros
fléchés vers le Fonds national pour
l'emploi pérenne dans le spectacle son
peps cette progression des crédits dans
une trajectoire haussière révélatrice
d'une soupe budgétisation constante
depuis 2019 dans ces conditions nous
nous interrogeons sur la fiabilité de la
prévision budgétaire pour 2023
venons-en désormais au programme 175
dédié au patrimoine au pluriel et qui
devrait être dotés de 1,1 milliard
d'euros en 2023 soit une protection lors
une progression là encore de plus de 7%
par rapport à 2022 ce financement est
complété par des soutiens hors budget
mobilisant nos concitoyens dont pour
Notre Dame de Paris dans le montant 849
millions d'euros devraient dépasser le
coût des travaux actuellement estimés à
703 millions d'euros et le taux du
patrimoine pour lequel le ministère des
gèle la réserve de précautions chaque
année ce jeu comme l'augmentation prévue
des crédits du fond incitatif
partenarial vient d'ailleurs compenser
la tendance à la baisse des crédits
déconcentrés près de la moitié de la
progression des crédits dédiés au
programme 175 relève de mesures
destinées à tenir compte de l'inflation
et de la hausse des coûts sur les 37,4
millions d'euros dédiés à cet objectif
près des deux tiers
péché vers les opérateurs la majoration
des coûts est déjà constatée sur
plusieurs chantiers encadrés par l'État
s'agissant précisément des chantiers
nous avons noté que 2023 devrait être
marqué par l'ouverture de la cité de la
Francophonie à Villers-Cotterêts le coût
du chantier était initialement évalué à
185 millions d'euros avant d'être porté
à 209 millions d'euros sa réalisation
n'a d'ailleurs été permise que par la
mise en oeuvre du plan de relance cette
expérience coûteuse doit servir de
points cardinal dans la réflexion à
mener sur d'autres grandes opérations
d'investissement et je pense en
particulier à l'aménagement du site de
Clairvaux qui se voit doté de 15
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement pour 2023 démarrage assez
modestes chacun en conviendra en regard
du coup global de cette opération
au-delà de la hausse des dépenses
contraintes nous relevons une hausse
importante des prix d'acquisition
d'oeuvre les plus importantes qui
auraient vocation à enrichir nos
collections publiques
les niveaux d'aide judication dans les
ventes aux enchères s'établissent
désormais très régulièrement à un niveau
4 à 10 fois supérieur voire davantage à
celui des estimations
enfin si la reprise de la fréquentation
des établissements publics dédiés au
patrimoine a été plus importante que
prévu en 2022 l'horizon ne semble pas
pour autant totalement dégagé en raison
de plusieurs incertitudes
l'effet de l'inflation bien sûr sur les
dépenses culturelles l'absence de retour
de certaines clientèles en pensant en
particulier à la clientèle les touristes
chinois et la perspective d'une
fermeture le temps des Jeux Olympiques
est paralympiques en 2024 je cède
maintenant la parole à mon collègue
Didier Rambaud pour les programmes de
124 et 361
je fais quoi moi alors
comme le rapporteurs
Rambaud de prendre la suite
madame le présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission
mesdames les rapporteurs pour avis mes
chers collègues ce projet doit finance
pour 2023 prévoit une majoration de la
dotation du programme dédié à la
transmission des savoirs et à la
démocratisation de la culture de près de
6,5% en crédit de paiement par rapport à
2022 les crédits devraient ainsi
atteindre environ 800 millions d'euros
les moyens financiers dédiés aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
culturel et à l'insertion
professionnelle devrait progresser de 32
millions en CP afin de répondre à quatre
objectifs la révélation des bourses sur
critères sociaux le renforcement des
subventions de fonctionnement et
d'investissement des écoles d'art et
d'architecture la mise en oeuvre des
grands projets d'investissement de ces
mêmes écoles et enfin le soutien aux
établissements territoriaux
d'enseignement supérieur en ciblant
notamment le statut des enseignants au
sein de ces écoles
reste une interrogation sur la dynamique
baissière des taux d'insertion
professionnelle des étudiants
issus du domaine du spectacle vivant
afin de répondre à ce défi il convient
de mettre en place un véritable
accompagnement en déclinant le modèle du
Jeune Théâtre National associé au
Conservatoire National Supérieur d'Art
Dramatique de Paris et au Théâtre
National de Strasbourg qui organise
rencontre et auditions prend en charge
une partie des jeunes artistes engagés à
la suite des auditions programme des
maquettes de premier spectacle et
élabore un annuaire des artistes issus
des 11 écoles nationales d'art
dramatique par ailleurs 13 millions
d'euros sont fléchés vers des
établissements structurants au sein des
écoles de la création et du patrimoine
cet apport doit être salué ce qui ne
doit pas nous empêcher de rappeler
l'importance des restes à payer sur les
chantiers couverts par le programme 361
venons-en maintenant un dispositif
auquel je suis attaché le Pass Culture
déployé dans toute la France depuis mai
2021 étendu en 2022 aux jeunes de 15 ans
et plus et aux élèves à partir de la
quatrième le Pass Culture sera ouvert
aux jeunes 6e et 5e en 2023
208,5 millions d'euros sont prévus en
2023 pour le financement du dispositif
qui est rappelons-le aujourd'hui le
deuxième opérateur du ministère de la
Culture derrière la Bibliothèque
nationale de France plus de 2,1 million
de jeunes sont aujourd'hui inscrits sur
l'application et 14 millions de
réservations de produits culturels ont
été opérés via le pass pour un montant
total de 235 millions d'euros
concrètement 87% des jeunes concernés
ont acquis un bien culturel par cette
intermédiaire le pack le Pass Culture
est un dispositif qui a mes yeux et
pertinent et je continuerai de soutenir
mais comme vous le savez madame la
ministre je reste attentif à sa mise en
oeuvre pour que l'efficacité puisse être
améliorée le Pass ne peut se résumer une
simple plateforme d'achat de bien et de
services et doit être éditorialisé en
vue de mettre en place un véritable
parcours culturel lors des prochains
mois avec mon collègue Vincent amblay
nous allons vérifier que le Pass ne
servent pas au financement d'achat lié
au parcours scolaire et qui puisse
contribuer à faire évoluer des pratiques
culturelles l'accent pourrait être ainsi
mis sur l'accès au spectacle vivant par
exemple j'en profite également pour
tordre le cou à quelques rumeurs j'ai
entendu récemment sur le fait que le
Pass Culture se rédigible d'aller au
parc de loisirs non ce n'est pas le cas
pour en revenir aux pistes aux pistes
d'amélioration du Pass Culture je crois
également que nous devons renforcer
l'accès des jeunes non ce que la
scolarisé au Passe seul 3,7% des
inscrits sur l'application déclaré ne
pas être scolarisé or ce ratio est plus
faible que le nombre de jeunes non
scolarisés
apporter à l'ensemble de la population
visée et bien sûr sans oublier les zones
rurales et périurbaines où l'offre
culturelle hélas n'est pas la même et où
les questions de mobilité j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous le dire se pose en
tout état de cause le Pass Culture ne
doit pas résumer aussi l'effort de
l'État en faveur de l'éducation
artistique et culturelle autrement dit
la montée en charge budgétaire de
l'application ne doit pas s'effectuer au
détriment des moyens qui lui sont
traditionnellement dédiés nous ne
pouvons que déplorer le fait que les
indicateurs rattachés au programme
mettent d'ailleurs en avant une
réduction de la part des enfants et
adolescents ayant bénéfié bénéficier
d'une action d'éducation artistique et
culturelle et une baisse de l'effort en
faveur des territoires prioritaires pour
conclure je souhaite revenir sur le
programme 224 soutien aux politiques du
ministère qui devrait être dotés
d'environ 810 millions d'euros en 2023
comme lors de l'exercice précédent la
masse salariale devrait devrait croître
en 2023 atteignant ainsi 516 millions
d'euros 67% de cette progression résulte
de mesure catergure catégorielles dont
le plan de rattrapage indemnitaire
celui-ci doit permettre de renforcer son
attractivité et d'éviter des vacances de
poste prolongées le projet immobilier
Camus lancé en 2019 prévoit la
rénovation des locaux et l'aménagement
de nouveaux bureaux au sein du ministère
de la Culture devrait ainsi en 2023
passer de 7 à 3 sites initialement
établis à 36,6 millions d'euros le
budget prévisionnel a été actualisé en
2022 pour être porté à
55,48 3 millions d'euros l'exercice 2023
devrait voir la dotation numérique du
ministère continuer à progresser
26,52 millions d'euros seront ainsi
dédiés au renforcement de la
transformation numérique et de la
cybersécurité et à la mise en place
d'outils permettant de renforcer et de
fiabiliser le suivi économique de
l'activité des secteurs qu'il
subventionne en ciblant notamment la
fréquentation au sein des opérateurs ou
la ou la dynamique du spectacle vivant
la mise en place de ces systèmes
d'information devrait continuer à
contribuer à faciliter la gestion des
crédits dédiés aux établissements
subventuels subventionnés et permettre
une meilleure prévision budgétaire cela
est tard étant pardon contenu des moyens
supplémentaires dédiés à la culture que
je souhaite souligner une nouvelle fois
la commission des finances a décidé
d'approuver les crédits de la mission
culture merci
la parole est maintenant madame Sabine
drixaire rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de la culture d'éducation et
de la communication
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
le monde du patrimoine appréhendait le
niveau des crédits en 2023 après les
aides exceptionnelles dont il a
bénéficié pendant la crise sanitaire
nous sommes satisfaits de constater que
l'État maintient son effort dans ce
secteur nécessite des investissements
qui s'accommodent mal d'un financement
par à coup le niveau de l'inflation
reste néanmoins motif d'inquiétude tant
pour les musées que pour la poursuite
des chantiers de restauration car le
budget 2023 n'en compense que
partiellement les effets à cet égard la
Commission de la culture regrette que
les crédits destinés à la restauration
des monuments historiques ou à la
rénovation des équipements patrimoniaux
des collectivités territoriales ne
soient pas revalorisées à l'exception du
fond incitatif et partenariale compte
tenu de l'effet ciseaux auxquels les
collectivités sont confrontées des
problèmes d'ingénierie qu'elle rencontre
il aurait été utile que celle-ci soit
davantage accompagné
nous souhaitions vous interpeller madame
la ministre sur la situation
préoccupante des effectifs des services
déconcentrés en charge du patrimoine qui
ne leur permet plus d'assumer
correctement leur mission de conseils et
d'expertise auprès des collectivités
territoriales et des propriétaires
privés il y a urgence à recruter et à
revaloriser l'attractivité de ses postes
nous sommes également préoccupés par le
faible niveau des crédits alloués à
l'architecture et aux espaces
patrimoniaux remarquables face aux
enjeux de régénération des centres
anciens et de transition écologique et
énergétiques il ne faudrait pas que le
patrimoine se retrouve la victime
collatérale de ces politiques fautes
d'avoir pris en compte suffisamment tôt
à quel point il constitue au contraire
un levier de revitalisation comme de
sobriété énergétiques nous sommes
convaincus que la réhabilitation du bâti
ancien constitue d'un point de vue
durable l'avenir de la construction
parmi vos priorités madame la ministre
figurent à juste titre la transition
énergétique de votre ministère si nous
saluons les efforts destinés à améliorer
les performances des bâtiments des
opérateurs nous pensons que votre action
doit aller plus loin dans la mesure où
il est aujourd'hui avéré que la
transition telle qu'elle est amorcée va
affecter la pérennité de tout le
patrimoine dont votre ministère est
pourtant chargé d'assurer la
préservation
madame la ministre les dispositions de
la loi climat et résilience vont
entraîner ni plus ni moins que la
disparition des caractéristiques
architecturales françaises car ni les
nouvelles modalités de calcul du DPE ni
les solutions de rénovation thermique
préconisées ne sont adaptées au bâtis
d'avant 1948 sans vouloir soustraire le
patrimoine aux impératifs de transition
écologique nous sollicitons votre
intervention pour que les travaux de
rénovation énergétique ne se traduisent
pas par la perte du patrimoine et du
savoir-faire de notre pays ainsi que par
un gaspillage d'argent public il y a
urgence à engager un travail
interministériel pour mieux concilier
préservation du bâti ancien et
transition écologique nous avons
identifié dans notre rapport plusieurs
leviers d'action et nous espérons
vraiment madame la ministre pouvoir
compter sur votre engagement pour les
mettre en oeuvre très vite car de
nombreuses maisons partout en France
sont déjà fait les frais de ce
malentendu réglementaire je vous
remercie
madame Sylvie Robert remporteur pour un
vie ici également de la commission
culture éducation communication
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la nouvelle
progression des crédits des programmes
créations et transmission des savoirs et
démocratisations de la culture constitue
bien évidemment un réel soulagement nous
vous remercions Madame la Ministre
d'être parvenu à convaincre l'ensemble
du gouvernement que le secteur culturel
devait rester une priorité pour 2023 et
le secteur de la création a encore
besoin d'accompagnement si les
collectivités publiques l'ont aussi très
largement soutenu pendant la crise
sanitaire sa situation demeure fragile
il faut le dire qu'il est affecté depuis
7 ans par des cris successives les
attentats 2015 la pandémie le covid-19
et désormais la hausse des prix de
l'énergie malheureusement aucune de ces
crises n'est encore véritablement
surmontée la vague d'attentat s'est
traduite par un relèvement durable et
considérable des coûts de sécurité des
établissements quant à la crise
sanitaire ses effets restent encore
palpables que ce soit sur la
fréquentation ou sur les recrutements
avec une vraie crise d'évocation
observable sur l'ensemble des différents
emplois à cela s'ajoutent les
changements profonds des comportements
des publics qui mettent de plus en plus
à mal les modèles traditionnels éc des
établissements que ce soit d'ailleurs
des établissements publics comme privé
dans ce contexte on comprend que la
crise énergétique et l'inflation
généralisée cristallise les inquiétudes
puisqu'elles affectent non seulement les
dépenses des établissements mais aussi
leur recette les Français réduisent
leurs dépenses de loisirs le mécénat est
en baisse et les collectivités
territoriales sont tentées de réduire
leurs engagements financiers pour faire
face à la hausse de leurs dépenses pour
faire face à ces difficultés nous vous
savons gré d'avoir choisi de faire
porter la priorité en 2023 sur l'emploi
ainsi que sur le renforcement des
marches artistiques des établissements
leur marge de manœuvre sont
effectivement réduites et la hausse de
leur tarif ou la révision à la baisse de
leur programmation auraient des effets
désastreux tant sur la fréquentation que
sur la création il reste néanmoins
désormais à accompagner cet effort
financier par un renforcement du
dialogue entre votre ministère les
acteurs culturels et les collectivités
territoriales il s'agit d'un besoin
essentiel pour ce secteur qui nécessite
de disposer de visibilité très en amont
du fait des contraintes on le sait de
leur programmation c'est vrai aussi pour
les crédits d'impôts mais je pense que
l'on en parlera il est vrai par exemple
que l'affaire autour des possibles
annulation de festival en 2024 du fait
des Jeux Olympiques aurait peut-être pu
être évité si des concertations
préalables étaient intervenues alors la
commission de la culture est convaincue
que le soutien à la création artistique
à l'éducation artistique et culturelle
et aux établissements d'enseignements
passent par rémeyer dialogue et par le
développement de nouvelles modalités de
contractualisation avec les
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie et je vous propose donc de
donner un avis favorable à l'adoption de
ces crédits je vous remercie
alors dans la suite de la discussion je
vous rappelle que le temps de parole est
attribué à chaque groupe
contient et l'intervention de
distribution générale et les
explications de vote et que le
gouvernement dispose d'un temps maximum
de temps de parole de 15 minutes madame
a provoqué c'est à vous pour le groupe
Union centriste et pour 8 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
Culture Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues c'est
une longue période chahutée que le monde
de la culture traverse depuis trois ans
et si quelques éclaircies ont pu
parcourir son ciel les nuages
s'amoncelle à nouveau et avec eux leur
cortège inquiétude en 2020 débute la
crise sanitaire les confinements les
restrictions et la cruelle sanction de
ne pas faire partie des essentiels
depuis on le sait et parce qu'il a fallu
qu'elle nous manque pour qu'on fasse
cela soit compris la culture est un bien
vital or la guerre aux portes de
l'Europe l'inflation la crise climatique
le retour prudent différent des publics
nous ordonnent d'anticiper de crainte
que nous quitte à nouveau dépendantiers
de la vie culturelle les budgets
examinés aujourd'hui sont pleinement
concernés par ces crises et nous saluons
ici madame la ministre le réel est fort
budgétaire réalisé c'est un marqueur de
la reconnaissance du rôle majeur joué
par la culture dans cette bien rude
période néanmoins des inquiétudes
demeure pour aujourd'hui mais aussi pour
demain
comme souligné par nos deux rapporteurs
Sylvie Robert et Sabine dragster nous
savons tous que cela nécessitera coup
sur un suivi budgétaire attentif pour
réagir à temps via des projets de loi de
finances rectificative que ce soit les
programmes 175 patrimoine 361
transmission des savoirs et
démocratisation au centre 31 créations
de grands défis attendent votre
ministère en 2023 d'abord l'inflation et
le coût de l'énergie l'hypothèse de plus
4,3% est déjà caduque et la hausse des
crédits 7% pour le 361 7 pour le 175 et
10 pour le 131 devait devrait en être
atténué d'autant le soutien aux
opérateurs étant progression mais le
surcoût énergétique estimait le rend
déjà bien insuffisant pour les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
d'Art les conservatoires ou les écoles
d'architecture même constat en matière
de patrimoine c'est en plus à une forte
hausse du coup des matières premières
des chantiers qu'il faut faire face la
réalité rattrape vite les établissements
structures et symboles s'imposent à
leurs arbitrages budgétaires mettant en
péril la formation artistique les
horaires et durée d'ouverture le
calendrier des créations les tarifs et
les délais des chantiers des annulations
sont envisagées des reports des
fermetures à ces mesures extrêmes devoir
devoir répondre un soutien extrême
ensuite la question des ressources
humaines sur le terrain festival des
établissements culturels constatent un
manque Crillon des métiers nécessaires à
leur fonctionnement qui soit technique
administratif ou artistique même constat
pour l'enseignement les écoles
d'architecture elles ont besoin de
moyens supplémentaires car il va falloir
mettre en place des formations initiales
et continue pour répondre au défi de la
mise aux normes énergétique dans les
Dracs le manque d'attractivité est
pointé il existe ainsi des postes
vacants dans le secteur du patrimoine
sur 12 postes ouvertes en sortie à
l'école de Chaillot seul 4 sont pourvus
le recours au contractuel ne pallit pas
les manques à cette crise de la
ressource en matière de professionnels
s'ajoute cellier au coût des
revalorisations salariales liés à
l'inflation le ministère fait un réel
pour compenser quel que soit le secteur
mais tous l'écosystème culturel dans sa
très grande diversité de statues et de
métiers n'en bénéficiera pas les
collectivités et les acteurs privés sont
eux aussi concernés les arbitrages ne
vont pas toujours vers la compensation
et l'offre culturelle dans sa diversité
en effet fragilisés outre ces deux
sujets madame la ministre trois autres
nous alertes le premier concerne
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
le rôle du Pass Culture en ces temps où
les choix budgétaires sont complexes on
ne peut que s'étonner de son montant
représentant 25% du programme 6061 ceci
des notes singulièrement avec la
sobriété budgétaire qui s'impose aux
acteurs de la culture la SAS peut
cultures ne connaît pas la crise ensuite
si la part collective est une avancée
pour faciliter l'accès à des actions
culturelles dans les établissements
scolaires du second degré elle interroge
sur son usage et sa mise en oeuvre en
matière de AC le Pass à une logique
d'offre à laquelle les établissements
répondent
la demande alors que le AC est avant
tout un projet une médiation vers la
culture c'est pourtant cette médiation
entre enseignant élèves structure
créateur et collectivités construites
dans le temps qui fait la réussite de
leac la labellisation proposée tant à
exclure certaines actions ou artistes et
à diminuer les interactions avec les
collectivités la simplification extrême
du process de commande confine à une
ubérisation de l'EAC nous ne souhaitons
pas qu'elle se résume au passes cultures
la transformant en un système d'achat
dans une boutique d'action d'artistes et
d'événements le second point concerne
les festivals il subissent une loi des
séries la crise sanitaire la crise
énergétique les surcoutes de
programmation la crise climatique et
maintenant la menace d'annulation de
décalage lié aux JO à tout cela s'ajoute
le retour hésitant du public le fond
festival ne suffira pas les
organisateurs attendent enfin la
nomination d'un référent ministère et de
référents dans les Dracs ils entendent
d'être défendus lors de tous les
arbitrages qui sont faits et qui les
concernent si les plus grands et les
plus solides parviennent non sans
difficulté à tenir tous les autres sont
en danger or par leur nombre leur
diversité et leur présence dans tous les
territoires ils sont des moteurs de la
vie culturelle singulièrement sur la
période estivale les JO sont évidemment
un rendez-vous exceptionnel et une
fierté pour notre pays mais les
festivals ne doivent pas en être la
victime désignée à cause d'un manque de
moyens logistique ou de compétences
phagocytées par ce grand événement enfin
le troisième point concerne la situation
du patrimoine confrontée à l'arrivée du
diagnostic de performance énergétique le
DPE si la transition écologique et
l'amélioration énergétique du bâti sont
des nécessités cela ne doit ni nuire au
patrimoine ni détériorer la qualité de
nos communes en écho à l'intervention de
notre rapporteur Sabine dresser je ne
peux que vous alerter sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment le DPE suit des
règles inadaptées au bâti début avant
1949 il lui est même délétère or nul
besoin d'être spécialiste pour
comprendre que l'isolation par
l'extérieur sur un bâti ancien en pierre
ou un torchis par exemple est une erreur
technique c'est aussi une faute
vis-à-vis d'identité de nos vies les
villages et façon les particularismes
locaux nuisant à la qualité du cadre de
vie il y a donc urgence à faire évoluer
les critères du bon sphère du bon sens
car la machine à défigurer par un an le
disquement systémique est en marche pour
conclure Madame la ministre vous l'avez
compris dans ces moments où tout confine
à l'urgence où il est nécessaire de
faire des choix dégager des priorités ou
le temps du dialogue évite raccourci
voire inexistant le ministère de la
culture doit être fort savoir entendu
ces propositions retenues et ce quel que
soit l'attend le cutter ministère Kojo
Adem par exemple trop nombreuses sont
les annonces ou décisions ou la culture
et le patrimoine sont concernés et pour
autant le sentiment est donné que le
ministère est peu concerté
madame la ministre le groupe pucer votre
a favorablement ce budget mais au-delà
de ce vote parce que nous soutenons
ardemment la culture et le patrimoine et
que l'essentiel est bien là le groupe UC
témoigne ici de sa vigilance et de ses
inquiétudes préservez-vous la poésie de
notre pays le patrimoine et les paysages
en sont les crins la culture et l'air
qu'on y respire je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Bernard fialet qui a l'air pour
5 minutes pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique social
européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
défendre le budget de la culture
pourraient seulement consister à relever
ces externalités positives sur
l'économie en particulier en particulier
touristique et son rôle social en
réalité l'État doit se comporter en
promoteur sans attendre l'exacte
contrepartie comptable de son
investissement notre pays à la
responsabilité de soutenir la culture
qui fait tout simplement partie de notre
système de valeurs républicaine elle
nous oblige elle est l'expression de la
liberté selon une formule quantienne en
cela si j'ose dire la culture
est par essence essentielle à ce titre
elle a d'ailleurs trouvé sa place dans
le plan de relance qui a permis à nos
acteurs et institutions du monde
culturel de traverser la crise liée la
pandémie de covid je salue cet effort et
sa pérennisation à travers le programme
de commande publique monde nouveau qui
se poursuivra avec un premier soutien de
10 millions d'euros en 2023 en direction
du spectacle vivant et des arts visuels
j'en profite pour rappeler notre
amendement de bonification du crédit
d'impôt pour le spectacle vivant adopté
en première partie du projet de loi de
finance et nous espérons qu'il survivra
à la navette parlementaire Madame le
Ministre en attendant mes chers
collègues la culture devra affronter
d'autres difficultés je pense bien
entendu au coût de l'énergie ainsi qu'à
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens qui pourraient les container
craindre à sacrifier les activités
culturelles en outre la question des
Jeux Olympiques et par olympiques de
2024 est un sujet d'inquiétude madame la
ministre le monde culturel attend des
réponses car certains de ces acteurs ont
besoin de se projeter dans le temps pour
des raisons évidentes de programmation
pour faire face à tout cela le projet de
loi de finances pour 2023 affiche une
progression globale d'environ 7% des
crédits de la mission culture c'est un
effort signification mais l'action
publique doit respecter l'objectif
d'équité la culture c'est pour tous et
sur tous les territoires
s'agissant tout d'abord nos territoires
je souhaite évoquer la question du
patrimoine un levier essentiel du
dynamisme local et surtout un marqueur
fort de l'identité de nos villes
départements ou région les crédits du
programme 175 augmenteront de 7,5% en
2023 c'est une bonne chose mais ce
programme ne reflète pas l'ensemble de
l'effort de l'État en faveur du
patrimoine
j'ajouterai qu'il est fortement
concentré sur les monuments historiques
et les musées
par conséquent il n'est pas inutile de
souligner l'action très volontaire des
collectivités locales selon la Cour des
comptes elles investissent en moyenne
chaque année 650 millions d'euros en
direction du patrimoine avec un regard
appuyé sur le petit patrimoine de
proximité qui est aussi essentiel
mais tous les moyens réunis y compris
ceux de la Fondation du Patrimoine et de
la mission Berne dont le fameux loto
suffiront-ils à couvrir les défis
auxquels est confronté notre patrimoine
le renchérissement des chantiers de
restauration et la nécessité d'accélérer
la transition énergétique sont deux
enjeux imminent et le premier va
clairement oblitérer une partie de la
hausse des crédits budgétaires
s'agissant de la transition énergétique
il convient d'éviter de mettre doigt
d'eau patrimoine et développement
durable dans les deux cas il s'agit de
conserver notre héritage
aujourd'hui nous disposons des outils
technologiques pour concilier les
mesures de protection du patrimoine et
les objectifs de développement durable
il faudra bien sûr bien former les
architectes pour cela les moyens
déconcentrés de l'État en charge du
patrimoine doivent être à la hauteur or
ils sont très contraints actuellement
enfin je souhaite souligner un deuxième
point celui de la démocratisation de la
culture
l'égal accès à la culture est un
objectif de la politique publique du
ministère à travers le programme 361
dans ce cadre le Pass Culture focalise
beaucoup l'attention pour ne pas dire
les crédits puisqu'il absorbe jusqu'à
25% du programme
moi je me réjouis de sa montée en charge
et de son ouverture à de nouvelles
classes d'âge mais je m'interroge
également sur le fait que le spectacle
vivant et les musées recueillent une
bien moindre attention il y a donc un
effort à faire pour inciter les jeunes à
plus de diversité dans leur pratique
culturelles il faut comme l'avait
rappelé Malraux en 66 je cite faire ce
que la Troisième République avait
réalisé dans sa volonté républicaine
pour l'enseignement il s'agit de faire
en sorte que chaque enfant de France
puisse avoir droit au tableau au théâtre
au cinéma etc comme il a le droit à
l'alphabet
dans cette perspective il me semblerait
souhaitable de ne pas négliger les
autres volets du programme dont les
actions plus traditionnelles d'éducation
artistique et culturelles mes chers
collègues je le répète parce qu'elle est
au cœur de notre projet républicain la
culture doit toujours être soutenue le
groupe RDSE approuvera donc les crédits
de la mission merci Madame laure-d'arcos
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues avec le
projet de loi de finances vient le temps
des promesses celui de 2023 n'échappa à
la règle les moyens de la mission
culture sont abondés à 205 de 250
millions d'euros ce qui représente une
augmentation de 7,4% par rapport à la
loi de finances initiale pour 2022 il
s'agit évidemment d'un motif de
satisfaction et nous aurions tort de
considérer cet effort budgétaire comme
négligeable mais est-il pour autant
suffisant je n'en suis pas certaine tous
ceux qui sont investi dans de cette
mission essentielle de préserver la
patrimoine de favoriser l'acte de
création de promouvoir la culture pour
tous sa larme de l'augmentation
exponentielle des coûts énergétiques la
filière du spectacle et le patrimoine
sont particulièrement impactés
certes l'Etat est intervenu puissamment
dans un passé récent afin d'aider le
monde de la culture à faire face aux
conséquences de la crise sanitaire par
un certain nombre de mesures
transversales le mystère de la Culture a
pour sa part apporté une réponse forte
et singulière qu'il faut saluer et qui
se prolongera en 2023 afin notamment de
permettre aux structures de surmonter
les difficultés actuelles mais
l'augmentation des crédits apparaît
d'ores et déjà absorbée par l'inflation
chaque programme de la mission bénéficie
d'un abondement
de la mission bénéficie d'un abonnement
par rapport à l'an dernier le programme
175 consacré au patrimoine finance comme
vous le savez les politiques de
préservation et d'enrichissement du
patrimoine culturel français dans ce
cadre il est prévu l'accroissement des
moyens alloués au fond incitatif et
partenarial pour les collectivités a
fait le potentiel financier le
renforcement du plan de sécurité
cathédrale et un soutien renforcé à la
politique d'archéologie préventive ce
sont des propositions que nous pouvons
approuver
l'action de l'État se tradura également
par un investissement accru dans la
rénovation et la modernisation des
établissements culturels avec notamment
l'augmentation de 3 millions d'euros de
la subvention d'investissement du Centre
des monuments nationaux où le
renforcement des capacités
d'investissement du musée d'Orsay avec
1,5 millions supplémentaires je m'en
réjouis à titre personnel la création à
travers le programme 131 bénéficie d'une
attention particulière avec l'ambition
de soutenir l'emploi artistique et les
artistes auteurs de 13 millions d'euros
sont consacrés à cette action je
voudrais aussi souligner le renforcement
des moyens alloués aux opérateurs de la
création et la poursuite des projets
d'investissement ambitieux dans les
institutions emblématiques de ce secteur
à hauteur de 13,5 millions d'euros
enfin la transmission des savoirs et la
démocratisation de la culture qui
doivent être au coeur de notre pacte
républicain bénéficie elle aussi d'un
soutien renouvelé le passe culture est
désormais trouvé son rythme de croisière
et il est essentiel que chaque jeune
collégiens ou lycéen puisse bénéficier
d'une offre diversifiée sur l'ensemble
du territoire
l'effort en faveur de ce dispositif ne
doit cependant pas se traduire par la
diminution concomitante des moyens
alloués au territoire prioritaire et à
l'éducation artistique et culturelle tel
ne semble pas être le cas concernant
cette dernière à ce jour elle recouvre
des réalités plus très hétérogènes par
les formes qu'elle revêt la pluralité
des acteurs impliqués et la diversité
des territoires où elle se déploie parce
qu'elle est indispensable à la
démocratisation de la culture et
renforce l'égalité des chances elle doit
être soutenue sans réserve
je suis par ailleurs heureuse de
constater les efforts budgétaires
destinés à améliorer l'attractivité de
l'enseignement supérieur culture son
insertion dans le paysage de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche et de l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes diplômés pour
autant des difficultés persistantes
affectent la création je pense au
spectacle vivant privé confronté à de
fortes contraintes conjoncturelles
notamment la hausse généralisée des
coûts mais aussi les contrats
structurels avec des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre récurrentes après deux années
catastrophiques en termes d'activité et
de recettes l'année 2022 a été synonyme
de reprise en demi teinte l'équilibre
économique des festivals et quant à lui
particulièrement dégradée c'est toute
une filière qui s'interroge sur son
avenir et son modèle de développement
dans ce contexte il a été demandé
malheureusement sans succès une
prolongation du crédit d'impôt spectacle
vivant
au-delà de ce crédit d'impôt il sera
judicieux nécessaire de réfléchir
renforcement de la filière musicale et
du Centre national de la musique
cependant je n'anticiperai pas sur les
propositions que notre collègue Julien
barjetton pourrait être amené à formuler
dans le cadre de la mission
parlementaire que lui a confié la
première ministre
je ne veux pas conclure cette
intervention sans émettre un regret à
propos des réserves du gouvernement sur
les crédits d'impôts destinés aux
différentes filières de la culture que
j'ai défendu en séance samedi en 8 en
raison de l'orthodoxie budgétaire
poussée à l'extrême la plupart d'entre
eux n'a pas pu être prolongée mettant un
mal de nombreux acteurs il s'agit d'un
véritable sujet d'inquiétude même si
j'ai obtenu une avancée importante pour
les éditeurs de services de vidéos à la
demande mais avouez que c'est une bien
maigre consolation voici mes chers
collègues à grands traits les réflexions
que je souhaitais vous soumettre compte
tenu des mesures positives que comporte
le budget de la mission culture et
sénateurs du groupe les républicains et
mettront un avis favorable je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Vanina Paoli Gaga
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
le programme création dépasse pour la
première fois le milliard d'euros de
budget c'est une excellente nouvelle à
l'image de la hausse de 7 % des crédits
dédiés à la mission culture
les exceptionnelles arrivent à leur fin
mais plusieurs mesures fiscales sont
pérennisées jusqu'en 2024 comme le
crédit d'impôt pour les représentations
théâtrales d'oeuvres dramatiques par
exemple la fréquentation moyenne des
lieux de spectacles vivants et des arts
visuels restent inférieurs au niveau
observé en 2019 il est essentiel de
consolider la reprise d'activités après
la crise covid et pendant la crise de
l'énergie
je souligne les 10 millions d'euros
destinés aux dispositif monde nouveau
dont l'un des objectifs et de faciliter
l'accès à la culture en milieu rural ce
qui nous importe tous ici au Sénat chers
collègues notre groupe est
particulièrement attaché à la
démocratisation de l'offre culturelle
pour tous et partout
je rejoins en revanche les rapporteurs
de la commission qui alertent au sujet
de la multiplication des objectifs et
des labels qui peuvent souvent brouiller
l'action du ministère auprès des
professionnels de la culture
nous devons également rester en alerte
sur la possibilité d'annulation ou de
report de festivals les grands
événements de la culture en 2024 causée
par l'organisation des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques les établissements
publics dédiés au patrimoine nous
alertes également sur leur probable
fermeture pendant les Jeux ces
événements majeurs ne doivent pas causer
une crise passion de l'offre culturelle
je sais que mes collègues de la
commission culture éducation et
communications sont particulièrement
mobilisées en ce sens
concernant les mesures en faveur de la
transmission des savoirs et de la
démocratisation de la culture je
souligne les 50 millions d'euros de
mesures nouvelles qui cible
principalement la jeunesse c'est une
très bonne chose la jeunesse et notre
priorité
la revalorisation des subventions
destinées aux écoles nationales est un
point très positif cela permettra de
participer à la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments il ne faut pas oublier les
écoles d'art territoriales qui
nécessitent des mesures similaires
les collectivités qui en sont les
propriétaires n'ont pas toujours en
effet les moyens d'engager d'importantes
rénovation c'est très important pour nos
territoires madame la ministre
je me réjouis de la progression du Pass
Culture la dotation augmente de 9,5
millions d'euros pour atteindre 208,5
millions d'euros pour 2023 rien n'est
plus précieux que d'offrir à nos jeunes
les moyens d'assouvir leur curiosité en
matière d'offres culturelle les élèves
de classe de 6e et de 5e qui
s'ajouteront à la liste des
bénéficiaires en 2023 pourront en
témoigner le programme patrimoine enfin
sera doté de 1,10 milliards d'euros en
crédit de paiement pour 2023 soit une
augmentation de 7,5%. c'est considérable
parmi les derniers crédits de paiement
qui restent du plan de relance 10
millions d'euros sont destinés au plan
cathédral comme l'ont souligné les
rapporteurs le financement des travaux
de conservation et de restauration de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris
proviennent quasi exclusivement du
mécénat
cette situation madame la ministre
m'amène à mentionner la reconversion du
site de l'abbaye de Clervaux qui se
trouve dans mon département de l'Aube
vous le savez un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt a été lancé trois candidats
ont été retenus sont en lice dans le
cadre d'un dialogue compétitif
l'état madame la ministre prend en
charge d'une partie des travaux avec 2
millions d'euros engagés dans le PLF
2023 pour restaurer le grand cloître
mais cet exemple nous appelle à
réfléchir sur les moyens de mobiliser
davantage les donateurs privés dans le
cadre de rénovation du patrimoine
aussi j'ai porté deux amendements
concernant le financement de la culture
dans ce projet de loi de finance qui
malheureusement n'ont pas prospérer le
premier vise à mobiliser l'épargne des
Français par la création d'un livre c
comme culture pour financer la création
artistique et le patrimoine culturel en
région le second vise à l'ancienne
souscription nationale un peu sur le
modèle en l'adaptant de ce qui a été
fait pour la rénovation de Notre-Dame
afin de soulager en fait le coût des
travaux engagés par l'État pour la
reconversion de Clairvaux j'appelle de
mes vœux une réflexion sur le sujet dans
les prochains mois enfin je souligne
l'urgence à soutenir la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments du patrimoine
qui doivent bénéficier de l'engagement
de l'État en faveur de la sobriété
énergétique vous le savez le coût de
l'inaction en matière de transition
écologique et astronomique plus on
attend plus ça coûte cher
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'examen des crédits
de la mission culture s'établit une
nouvelle fois dans un contexte d'extrême
fragilité d'un secteur en pleine
convalescence la crise covid a
profondément bouleversé les pratiques et
les fréquentations du public si les
fermetures totales les jauges et les
débats entre activités essentiels et non
essentielles sont aujourd'hui un mauvais
souvenirs la fréquentation n'a toujours
pas retrouvé son niveau d'avant crise
moins 15% par rapport à 2019 que ce soit
pour les musées ou les spectacles
vivants ou les arts de la Seine et ce
chiffre n'est qu'une moyenne des
écosystèmes culturels déjà fragiles sont
toujours en pleine incertitude les
menaces que font peser les JO sur la
saison culturelle 2024 n'est pas à
retrouver des perspectives rassurantes
à cette situation déjà difficile et
venue s'ajouter une autre crise non plus
sanitaire mais énergétique et
d'approvisionnement l'explosion des
coûts et des factures d'électricité et
de gaz ainsi que des matériaux de
construction
impactent très durement les équipements
culturels et leurs opérateurs et là
encore les plus petits sont les plus
exposés face à cet état de crise
multiple il faut le reconnaître l'état a
répondu présent en témoigne les deux
milliards d'euros débloqués pour la
culture durant le plan de relance ainsi
que les budgets de la mission culture à
proprement parler en constante
augmentation c'est d'ailleurs toujours
le cas cette année avec une augmentation
de 7% des crédits à louer
bien sûr ce soutien loin d'être parfait
on ne peut que regretter les efforts de
relance plus important sur le patrimoine
que la création l'absence de prise en
cause de la relation systémique en
tracteur surtout pour les petites
structures associatives ou culturelles
ou encore la place de la rénovation
énergétique encore limitée dans les
budgets
détaillons maintenant thème par thème
les grandes composants du budget sur le
patrimoine tout d'abord près de la
moitié de l'augmentation du budget du
programme 175 est dû à l'augmentation
des coûts et de l'inflation sur toute la
chaîne de valeur culturelles on y
retrouve ainsi des coûts en augmentation
très forte sur les chantiers de
plusieurs sites comme la cathédrale de
Soissons ou de saint Louis de Versailles
ainsi que les dépenses d'électricité qui
pourraient augmenter entre plus 128% et
plus 285% selon les estimations des
rapporteurs sur la création ensuite là
aussi l'effort est présent pour la
première fois le budget dépasse
désormais la barre symbolique du
milliard d'euros et il faut le saluer
l'augmentation vise aussi bien à
préserver les marges artistiques des
opérateurs et des acteurs culturels face
à l'inflation que soutenir l'emploi
vient la revalorisation du fond peps ou
encore de plusieurs projets
d'investissement et d'aménagement comme
le Théâtre National de Chaillot ou la
cité du théâtre vient enfin la
transmission des savoirs programme dans
lequel 25% du budget est consacré au
Pass Culture à hauteur de 208,5 millions
d'euros alors oui cette politique du
chèque y compris dans la culture n'est
pas l'idéal il pourrait être en effet
mieux cibler mieux accompagné
l'enveloppe pour être aussi plus
importantes mais tout ce qui concourt à
l'éveil culturel de la jeunesse salut
offrir un accès simple à la diversité
culturelle du pays même sans médiation
doit être saluée nous l'avons vu dans
chacun des programmes la crise
énergétique est une donnée majeure et
puisqu'on parle de facture énergétique
il ne faut pas oublier les collectivités
territoriales celle-ci représente en
effet 75% de l'investissement public en
direction de la culture 9,8 milliards en
tout contre 3,5 milliards pour l'État or
les directeurs des affaires culturelles
en collectivité anticipent des cadrages
budgétaires stricts pour l'exercice 2023
et laisse craindre une baisse du budget
des collectivités dédiées à la culture
de 10 à 20%. cette situation fait
craindre que le volet culturel soit une
variable d'ajustement pour les
collectivités si celle-ci ne sont pas
suffisamment soutenus en raison de la
faible reprise du secteur et malgré les
filets de sécurité et autres plans de
soutien voilà pourquoi nous vous
proposons par le biais d'un amendement
de soutenir davantage les collectivités
pour absorber l'augmentation des
factures de leur équipement culturel
nous ne nous compterons pas de gérer la
casse puisque nous vous proposons aussi
également d'aller plus loin dans la
planification ce que ne fait pas ce
budget nous souhaitons l'émergence d'un
fond correctement doté pour enfin
enclencher la rénovation énergétique des
équipements culturels plusieurs acteurs
culturels en fait part de leur volonté
de s'engager dans cette voie et nous
voyons au-delà de l'aspect climatique
que la crise énergétique leur a donné
raison nous soutiendrons naturellement
leur revendication enfin madame la
ministre je tiens ici à me faire le
relais de plusieurs inquiétudes
concernant la planification culturelle
sur le long terme de l'État même si
formellement cela n'est pas rattaché à
cette mission le plan France 2030 est
aussi un levier stratégique culturel on
y voit beaucoup d'émotions au NFP au NFT
pardon au metaves et à d'autres gadgets
techno culturels qui au-delà de l'effet
bulle médiatique à l'heure où nous
parlons ce sont parfois même souvent
avérés soit des arnaques être soit des
arnaques grossières soit des gouffres
financiers sans fin comment témoignent
aujourd'hui la situation de méta
l'affirmer de Facebook
madame le ministre il y a mieux à faire
ne serait-ce que pour la musique nous en
parlerons plus tard dans l'après-midi
mais le soutien au CNM doit être
renforcé que ce soit par le biais d'une
fiscalité affectée plus diversifiée ou
par un soutien de l'État renforcé nous
attendons ainsi les conclusions de la
mission confiée à notre collègue Julien
barbeton
le budget que nous examinons aujourd'hui
est un budget de rémission un budget qui
tente par encore de pallier des
difficultés d'un secteur à l'écosystème
certerie dans notre pays mais qui se
révèle aussi d'une infinie fragilité il
lui manque le souffle d'une grande
relance culturelle nous déterminerons
notre position de vote sur le budget
culture en fonction des débats sur les
amendements je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
Julien barjetton pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique progressiste
et indépendant
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
c'est un budget inédit en hausse
très forte après déjà des périodes
d'augmentation
3,7 milliards de crédits de paiement
soit une hausse record de 255 millions
d'euros presque 7,5%. tous les crédits
augmentent d'ailleurs c'est à dire que
effectivement on pourrait avoir parfois
des hausses différenciées etc en réalité
c'est une hausse qui est globale 7,6
pour le patrimoine plus de 10% pour la
création je note que pour la première
fois de son existence ce crédit cette
enveloppe dépasse le milliard d'euros
uniquement pour la création c'est la
première fois depuis que le ministère de
la Culture existe
6,7% pour la transmission la
démocratisation
4,7% pour le soutien en politique
transversale bref sont des hauts une
hausse globale du ministère et en plus
des hausses qui concernent tout tous ces
secteurs alors même que l'an dernier les
crédits étaient déjà en augmentation de
8%. il y a donc une structurel du budget
du ministère de la Culture et nous nous
en nous nous en réjouissons alors oui
c'est vrai ça intervient dans un
contexte d'inflation de crise
énergétique qui a été soulignée par les
différents interlocuteurs c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il y a aussi les mesures
qui concernent évidemment le traitement
et la réponse assez problème des mesures
ciblées cela a été dit notamment pour
faire face au surcoût dans les chantiers
a été évoqué la cathédrale de Soissons
20% pour faire face aux surco mais aussi
bien sûr 13 millions de plus pour le
château de Villers-Cotterêts parce que
et bien les chantiers culturels avec la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie et et
l'inflation et bien sont de plus en plus
chers mais également des hausses pour le
pouvoir d'achat des des agents 15,2
millions d'euros pour de mesures
catégorielles pour les agents du
ministère la poursuite du plan de
rattrapage indemnitaire en direction des
cordes de catégorie A+ la mise en oeuvre
de la revalorisation de la rémunération
des agents contractuels et la mise en
place d'un régime indemniteur pour les
enseignants chercheurs des écoles
nationales supérieures d'architecture
donc il y a aussi des mesures qui
concernent les personnels des ministères
pour faire face au contexte et des
mesures innovantes dans cette ensemble
le la phase 2 de mon nouveau c'est un
programme novateur qui s'adresse aux
créateur qui jouent dans de toutes les
gammes de tous les chants de la création
contemporaine le spectacle vivant les
arts visuels la musique le design etc 10
millions d'euros en plus en 2023
également bien sûr les métiers d'art
sont concernés 5 millions et demi de
plus pour les métiers d'art et puis il
faut rappeler que en dehors bien sûr des
crédit stricts du ministère il y a des
dispositifs innovants comme le loto du
patrimoine qui a permis de lever 100
millions d'euros en 4 ans pour le
patrimoine dit de proximité je crois
aussi que nous pouvons le ranger dans la
catégorie des dispositions innovantes et
utiles pour le secteur culturel cela
permet la poursuite d'investissement
dans les institutions emblématiques
comme sénateurs de Paris je voudrais
bien sûr citer les 5 millions d'euros
pour la salle Jean Vilar au Théâtre
National de Chaillot ou encore
l'extension de l'Institut du monde arabe
son agrandissement son réménagement un
peu plus de 2 millions d'euros mais
également 15 millions d'euros pour le
palais de la Cité bref les grands
chantiers qui sont effectivement très
importants et bien ce poursuivre et
prennent de l'ampleur en 2023 grâce à
tes effort budgétaires alors il a
souvent été évoqué mais je voudrais
parler moi aussi du Pass Culture parce
que le Pass Culture sert à gâcher un
certain nombre d'amendements qui qui
ponctionnent les crédits pour assurer le
recevabilité financière bon c'est la
règle c'est la règle de la Golf j'en
fais pas voilà il faut il faut aussi
bien sûr il faut vraiment considérer que
c'est bien sûr lié à la loi organique
relative au droit de finance il faut
bien trouver un gage mais je regrette
que ce soit un peu systématiquement ce
gage là qui soit ciblé c'est vrai qu'il
y a eu des crédits importants en plus
208 millions d'euros 9 millions et demi
par rapport à la finance 2022 c'est
parce que l'expérimentation a montré
qu'il fonctionne et statistiques par le
d'elle-même en la matière 2,1 millions
de jeunes qui sont inscrits sur
l'application 14 millions de
réservations de produits culturels qui
ont été faits grâce aux passes pour un
montant total de 235 millions d'euros et
87% des jeunes qui sont
enfin qui peuvent être concernés ont
fait l'acquisition d'un bien culturel
par ce biais donc c'est une réussite
alors évidemment c'était une
expérimentation audacieuse et qui a
évolué d'ailleurs et je crois qu'on peut
se sans féliciter beaucoup penser que
cela allait échouer mais finalement ça a
rencontré son son public elle est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs étendue et le
sera encore aux élèves de 6e et de 5e en
le fait de d'avoir accru la part
collective du Pass et va dans le bon
sens parce que bien sûr le Pass doit
être accompagné également d'une
médiation culturelle
crois à l'expérience écrivait William
butleriets prix Nobel de littérature en
1923 il a presque il y a 100 ans pas
tout à fait mais bientôt je sais que
vous aimez la poésie madame la ministre
et donc en la matière c'est une alliance
entre l'audace et l'expérience
c'est-à-dire que l'expérience peut
fournir le fait que même si on tente au
début quelque chose par Odace et bien on
prend en compte la façon dont
l'expérimentation a réussi ou non et on
a fait évoluer le Pass Culture je pense
que c'est ensemble comme cela qu'il faut
continuer c'est pour toutes ces raisons
l'augmentation globale et puis les
éléments plus particuliers que j'ai
soulignés que notre groupe votera les
crédits de la mission je vous remercie
monsieur Lucien Stanzione pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues
le droit de participer à la vie
culturelle et rarement considéré comme
un droit d'égalité en France la crise
sanitaire pour avantage d'avoir rendu
évident ce qui est considéré comme
essentiel et ce qui ne l'est pas les
crédits à loués à la mission culture
enregistrer une hausse remarquable oui
les priorités définies pour 2023 semble
en phase avec les besoins du secteur
est-ce que cela est vraiment le reflet
d'une politique ambitieuse peut-être
madame la ministre ces moyens
supplémentaires sont les bienvenus
est-ce suffisant et bien non
face à l'inflation et à la fin de l'aide
covid l'effort doit être plus grand la
France est forte de sa richesse
culturelle nous sommes reconnus dans le
monde entier soyons à la hauteur il y a
urgence les voyants sont au rouge
l'inégalité face à cette reprise à de
quoi nous inquiéter il y a un manque de
visibilité nos festivals ne sont plus
que jamais menacés par la crise
énergétique les petites structures se
demandent si elles survivront à l'hiver
pourquoi le quoiqu'il en coûte s'il est
fermetures définitivement des
établissements surviennent en 2023 et
peut-être bien en 2024 la première
source de financement de la culture en
France ce n'est pas les tâches ce sont
bel et bien les collectivités
territoriales on le sait les budgets de
la culture sont généralement les plus
concernés et les plus touchés
il est donc plus que jamais nécessaire
de soutenir nos territoires dans leur
pratique culturelles oui au fond
d'innovation territoriale de 2022 il
reste tout de même bon de souligner que
sa conception ne répond pas toujours
renforcement de la contre actualisation
entre l'État et les collectivités que
nous demandons plusieurs mesures
fiscales ça a été évoquées visant
favoriser la reprise d'activités sont
annoncées
outils phare de votre budget le Pass
Culture verra ses crédits augmenter afin
d'être accessible dès la sixième il ne
remplacera jamais une politique forte
d'éducation et de sensibilisation à la
culture
l'utilisation du Pass Culture reste
fortement inégal en fonction des
territoires il profite encore trop aux
industries culturelles le Pass Culture
doit être ne doit pas être substitué à
l'action de l'État madame la ministre
vous avez fait de la jeunesse l'une de
vos priorités nous vous en fait des
citons mais attention à l'Inachevée la
réforme des insta qui suscitent
l'inquiétude sur nos bancs en est un
exemple la modernisation de ces
établissements est indispensable nous
déplorons que de nouveaux moyens mis à
disposition pour les bourses ne
bénéficient qu'aux étudiants des écoles
nationales et pas à celle des écoles
territoriales enfin bien que l'amener
2022 est vu le retour à un format normal
des festivals leur avenir n'en est pas
moins compromis
dépenses énergétiques inflation des
montants du cachets
prestations extérieures absence de
personnels qualifiés à réfraction des
bénévoles pénuries du matériel la liste
des difficultés ne cesse de s'allonger
quelle est la réponse un engagement de
l'État modeste et une coordination avec
les collectivités trop faibles la
dotation du fond festival ne sera
injustement par revalorisé en 2023 au
regard de l'inflation et du coup de
l'énergie pire et l'annonce par le
ministre de l'intérieur des possibles
annulations et reports des festivals en
2024 un lien avec l'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques sans concertation
préalable avec les organisateurs
produisent SMA sendéac mais également
les lieux de festival le Hellfest les
Vieilles Charrues les européennes le
Festival d'Avignon et tous les autres il
est envisagé de changer les dates et
d'annuler certains festivals ceci a jeté
le plus sans doute sur les perspectives
de ces manifestations
l'inquiétude de notre commission est
très forte nous posons pas le sport à la
culture madame la ministre nous sommes à
vos côtés pour que vous fassiez entendre
raison au ministre de l'Intérieur et
encore plus à la première ministre pour
quand 2024 le sport ne soit pas l'opposé
à la culture ce n'est pas l'un ou
l'autre mais c'est bien le sport et la
culture en même temps la culture vecteur
d'émancipation d'épanouissement anime la
vie des quartiers et évite les errements
à certains de nos jeunes c'est la
culture qui doit venir aux Français non
l'inverse malgré ces quelques remarques
et réticences que vous prendrez sûrement
à votre compte et l'évolution positive
des moyens mis en oeuvre mon groupe se
prononcera favorablement pour votre
budget je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci
la parole
est ensuite à Monsieur Pierre ouzullias
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre époque est
celle de la crise de la médiation les
élus de la République que nous sommes la
vivent en permanence et sont ainsi
troublés quand l'exécutif décide de
consulter directement la nation par
l'intermédiaire de citoyens tirés au
sort se déconstructionnisme social est
aussi à l'oeuvre dans le domaine
culturel et le Pass Culture on est l'un
des symptômes il participe de l'illusion
qu'un jeune peut être sans médiation
l'acteur de sa propre formation
culturelle réduit à sa fonction de
consommateur il est douteux qu'il puisse
s'extraire de son habitude sociale pour
mettre à profit toutes les potentialités
menspatrices de la culture
la médiation culturelle telle qu'elle
avait été pensée par André Malraux aux
origines du ministère de la Culture
reposer sur le principe que l'accès à la
culture était entravé par des
déterminismes sociaux et géographiques
et qu'il fallait pour les dépasser je
cite
aller au devant de ceux qui ne savent
pas encore que l'offre culturelle
l'aurait accessible en s'affranchissant
de leurs conditions sociales culturelles
les citoyens accéder à l'or au droit
constitutionnels de légal accès de
l'enfant et de l'adulte à la culture
pensez comme une oeuvre de libération la
médiation devait s'exercer au plus près
des publics par une étroite
collaboration avec les collectivités et
les acteurs privés portés par l'essor
des maisons de la culture cette
politique d'aujourd'hui est reconsidérée
pour s'adapter aux nouveaux usages ainsi
l'enquête réalisée en 2008 sur les
pratiques culturelles en France a montré
que le téléphone est devenu le premier
terminal culturel Nomad et donc la porte
d'entrée principale vers de nombreux
univers culturels
l'efficacité technique de cet outil et
sa large diffusion dans la population
ont beaucoup apporté comme bénéfice
ainsi elle explique la progression
spectaculaire de l'écoute musicale
journalière qui a doublé en disant elle
était de 9 % en 1973 et elle est proche
aujourd'hui de 60% néanmoins cette
banalisation des supports audio cache
une socialisation de leurs usages par
exemple les modules en balade au
diffusion sont beaucoup plus écoutées
par les diplômés de l'enseignement
supérieur que par les autres à l'inverse
l'utilisation de l'outil numérique
semble préjudiciable à d'autres
pratiques culturelles sans doute parce
qu'elles exigent une participation plus
active c'est le cas de la lecture des
livres qui ont constant déclin ou de la
visite des musées et des monuments
historiques je doute que le Pass Culture
puisse contribuer à inverser ses
évolutions
pour les musées les monuments la visite
scolaire serait sans aucun doute plus
efficace pour rapprocher les jeunes
publics d'un patrimoine qui l'aurait de
plus en plus étrangers je pense
personnellement que la crise actuelle du
cinéma trouve peut-être certaines de ses
causes dans cette partie-làisation de la
pratique et dans la perte d'une culture
cinématographique ouverte à la diversité
de ces formes d'expression avec une
certaine nostalgie je me demande par
quoi ont été remplacés les Ciné Club des
lycées d'antan
en 2023 le budget de la culture
connaîtra une hausse qui est absolument
indéniable néanmoins on peut se demander
si elle pourra contribuer à la
nécessaire adaptation des politiques
publiques aux évolutions multiples des
pratiques la crise pandémique a montré
la fragilité des modèles économiques des
grands établissements fondés sur
l'illusion qu'ils pourraient trouver
leur équilibre sans dotation du
ministère
l'indispensable régénérescence de la
médiation culturelle oblige à
s'interroger sur les modalités de la
participation de tous les opérateurs du
ministère à une politique nationale qui
se donnerait pour suprême dessin de
rapprocher tous les publics de la
culture autrement dit en termes plus
techniques quelle est la capacité de la
Délégation générale à la transmission au
territoire et la démocratie culturelle
de votre ministère madame la ministre a
influé sur les multiples politiques
sectorielles mises en oeuvre par des
agences autonomes et financés par des
taxes affectées
depuis plusieurs années la commission de
la culture du Sénat alerte les ministres
successifs sur la nécessité de redonner
du sens au principe du droit d'accès à
la culture l'évolution des pratiques
culturelles fait de cette réfondation
une impérieuse nécessitée je vous
remercie merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur max
Bresson pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et Messieurs les rapporteurs
exclusiez quelques maladresses à mon
propos je voudrais vous interroger dans
trois directions et d'abord la
fréquentation des lieux culturels ce
n'est pas l'automne prometteur que vous
annonciez en juin le bilan est très
contrasté il y a ceux qui sont bien
redressés et des autres qui prennent de
plein fouet les nouveaux mots de
consommation et les nouvelles approches
numériques après la dure période de la
pandémie pour ne rien arranger le
ministre de l'Intérieur a récemment
annoncé pour 2024 l'annulation de toutes
les manifestations culturelles en marge
des Jeux olympiques de question me
viennent alors comment avons-nous pu en
arriver à une mesure si radicale quelle
garantie pouvez-vous donner aux
organisateurs de manifestations
culturels pour 2024 madame la il faut
les défendre se tenir à leur côté pour
leur donner les moyens de faire face à
ces défis et pour qu'il puisse aussi
s'engager dans une transformation
stratégique durable votre projet de
budget prend-il vraiment en compte un
fléchage des crédits alloués pour
répondre à la diversité de ces
situations on peut parfois en douter
d'autant plus qu'à ces évolutions
structurelles s'ajoutent des
conséquences de la crise de l'énergie et
de l'inflation qui amputent amputeront
aussi bien les budgets des organisateurs
que ceux des publics et surtout de ceux
qui sont les plus fragiles j'aurais donc
vivement que vos crédits ne soient pas
mieux fléchés en fonction de cette
diversité je regrette également
qu'au-delà des crédits on ne sentent une
inflexion des aides pour aider les
acteurs de la culture à faire face à ces
mutations les aider à s'engager dans
cette transformation stratégique durable
je voudrais ensuite te dire deux mots
sur le patrimoine j'ai compris que vous
n'avez guère apprécié mon commentaire
sur la rénovation du château de
Villers-Cotterêts entendons-nous bien
sahabitation n'est pas en question mais
vous vous ne pouvez pas m'empêcher de
penser que le projet culturel est arrivé
après la décision présidentielle et le
programme légitime de réhabilitation
j'ai eu comme l'impression qu'il fallait
remplir une case et que nous n'avions
pas un projet culturel au coeur de cette
réalité le rapporterait dit le reste
quand au dépassement budgétaire sur la
question du patrimoine je voudrais aussi
vous rappeler que notre commission est
attachée au rôle des ABS et qu'il est
souhaitable dans un pays comme le nôtre
que le déploiement nécessaire des ENR ne
nous conduisent pas au même erreurs de
défiguration des patrimoine et des
paysages comme nous avons pu le
connaître lors du déploiement d'autres
réseaux il faut donc préserver leur rôle
leur mission et leur présence sur le
terrain surtout comme la très bien dit
notre rapporteur Sabine très clair ce
réseau exceptionnel ne doit-il pas être
renforcé face à l'ampleur de la tâche
qu'il a devant lui sa réduction génère
des lenteurs et des prises de décision
parfois peu argumentés qui contribue sur
le terrain à des tensions avec les mers
et donc à remettre en cause la
pertinence même de leur expertise et de
leur raison d'être j'appelle à votre
vigilance je voudrais également espérer
que l'excellent rapport de nos collègues
en étalons et Pierre rouzoulias
retiennent la tension du gouvernement
oui dans notre pays une partie de notre
patrimoine ecclésiale et menacée oui les
urgent que c'est d'abord un travail
partenarial avec les autorités
religieuses les communes et l'État
l'acceptabilité des financements publics
communaux et départementaux figures et à
ce prix et la préservation de ce
patrimoine l'est également de même nous
regrettons qu'une politique adaptée en
matière de rénovation énergétique du
patrimoine historique n'émerge pas de ce
budget comme la souligner notre
rapporteur je finirai par deux mots sur
le Pass Culture ça montait en charge nos
camouf pas une discrimination sociale
préoccupante finalement se passe culture
profitent-ils vraiment à ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin de serait-il pas
nécessaire d'introduire des conditions
de ressources de même ne faut-il pas
relativiser son succès au vu des
inscriptions groupées dans certains
nombre d'écoles voilà quelques mots pour
évoquer les crédits de l'une des deux
missions cultures de votre ministère ils
sont en hausse il faut le saluer comme
la fécilie Robert notre rapporteur pour
avis je voudrais y ajouter un coup de
chapeau pour le dialogue que vous
souhaitez instaurer avec la Haute
Assemblée y compris sur le sujet
sensible des restitutions et de la
préservation des collections nationales
vous trouverez ici une assemblée
intransigeante sur les principes et
ouvertes sur les modalités je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Marie-Pierre meunier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les difficultés
incertitudes de la période actuelle
n'epargne aucun secteur y compris celui
du patrimoine la crise sanitaire avait
été l'occasion d'apporter des réponses
justes notamment en matière de soutien
public aux activités les plus
fragilisées ainsi le plan de relance a
permis à la fois d'accroître fortement
les crédits à l'eau au patrimoine et
d'engendrer une dynamique générale dans
les activités du secteur bénéficieront
encore en 2023 aussi nous saluons
l'augmentation des crédits du programme
175 à un rythme équivalent à celui de
l'ensemble de la mission soit 7% par
rapport à l'an dernier néanmoins cette
hausse doit être relativisée car ces
crédits ne seront plus complétés par
ceux du plan de relance qui avait permis
de dégager 227 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour le patrimoine et la
hausse qui représente 77 millions cette
année ne compensera que partiellement ce
montant
cette situation fait donc naître des
inquiétudes quant à la capacité de ce
budget à pouvoir accompagner des acteurs
du patrimoine qui vont devoir faire face
à l'inflation à l'explosion des tarifs
de l'énergie mais aussi à la poursuite
de la dynamique d'investissement initiée
par le plan de relance ainsi l'envoler
des prix de l'énergie va continuer à
peser fortement 2023 sur l'équilibre
financier des structures telles que les
musées et les monuments parallèlement
pour de nombreuses collectivités et
notamment les plus petites d'entre elles
le patrimoine ne sera peut-être pas
parmi les premières priorités elles
auront besoin d'un soutien plus affirmé
de l'État pour assurer la sauvegarde et
l'entretien du patrimoine dont elles ont
la charge nous défendons lors de chaque
pellef une répartition plus équilibrée
sur les territoires des crédits cette
année nous notons avec satisfaction que
l'augmentation des crédits en faveur de
l'entretien de la restauration des
monuments historiques hors grand projet
profite essentiellement au moyen
déconcentrés mise à disposition des
dragues pour la restauration de
monuments historique appartenant à
l'État parallèlement les moyens du fond
incitatif et partenariats pour les
monuments historiques des collectivités
à faible ressources sont accrues de 2
millions nous souhaitons néanmoins
attirer votre attention sur le mode de
répartition de l'enveloppe de crédit
locaux entre les différents projets en
effet il semble que les grosses
opérations consommant parfois plus de
50% de l'enveloppe sont favorisés or un
tel choix est nécessairement détriment
d'autres opérations de dimension plus
restreinte ainsi peu de travaux
d'entretien des monuments sont réalisés
et les communes moins versées sur le
patrimoine ne sont pas encouragés à
déposer des dossiers notre point de
vigilance est celui des moyens humains
des services déconcentrés de l'État
départementaux des dragues et des dates
car moins de personnels qualifiés c'est
forcément moins de soutien en petite
collectivités nous pouvons que regretter
une nouvelle fois que les crédits pour
l'architecture et les espaces protégés
soient en stagnation
il s'agisse de reconquête des
centres-villes ou de transition
énergétique de l'habitat ancien le
dispositif site patrimonial remarquable
est un outil très efficace qui
mériterait que le ministère sans
saisisse réellement j'en terminerai avec
les crédits en faveur du patrimoine
archéologique qui exprime un soutien
continu de l'archéologie préventive et
des missions de service public réalisé
par lindrap et les services
d'archéologie des collectivités
territoriales toutefois le surcroît
d'activité d'aménagement qui suit le
plan de relance nécessite des fonds
supplémentaires afin de pouvoir
continuer de répandre répondre aux
demandes sans allonger les délais de
chantier enfin nous saluons les
augmentations des crédits à destination
des centres de conservation et d'études
et pour le soutien aux fouilles
archéologiques programmées en
partenariat avec le CNRS et les
universités pour conclure si ce budget
reste un budget de soutien aux actions
de valorisation et de protection du
patrimoine nous émettons des réserves
quant à sa capacité répondre totalement
aux difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontées ces acteurs
la parole est maintenant madame elle se
Joseph pour 4 minutes et pour le groupe
les républicains
[Applaudissements]
la présidence madame la ministre mes
chers collègues malgré deux années
difficiles l'accès à la culture le
soutien au patrimoine doivent pouvoir
connaître un rebond nous sommes dans la
suite des actions menées dans le cadre
du plan de relance avec une reprise
timide et des pratiques culturelles qui
changent le mécénat diminue est
certaines aides de nos régions aussi si
nous saluons la hausse des crédits nous
regrettons le risque qu'elle soit
neutralisée par l'inflation nous
ressentons une certaine déception c'est
sur quoi annoncer son rédhibitoires et
éloigneront certains publics de l'accès
à la culture si nous saluons bien sûr
l'augmentation des crédits du programme
patrimoine il faut réfléchir à quelque
chose de plus ambitieux dans les
rénovations et réhabilitations dans nos
territoires il y a quelques mois avec
mon collègue Olivier Pacaud nous avions
rappelé l'importance du patrimoine privé
et du patrimoine local les crédits
doivent aussi bénéficier à ce patrimoine
de proximité
l'innovation culturelle se fait dans les
territoires c'est une clé pour la
reprise et pour le soutien à la vie
locale un vrai signal
il faut encourager toutes les solutions
qui permettent aux citoyens de financer
des projets le loto du patrimoine en a
été une mais il ne doit pas rester la
seule les circuits courts aussi
fonctionner dans le patrimoine il faut
permettre un financement direct
les services de l'État doivent pouvoir
parler aux acteurs locaux son filtre et
appuyer les projets de nos collectivités
même s'il faut saluer la prise en compte
de la crise énergétique il faut aussi
constater la majoration des coûts dans
les chantiers l'avenir de la culture
c'est d'abord la question à son accès
la reprise des accès au musée est ainsi
une positif mais des incertitudes paient
sur leur fréquentations et sur
l'amplitude d'ouverture cela va aussi
pour la jeunesse ce qui nous amène au
Pass Culture et la question de la
création et la découverte du patrimoine
c'est une aide appréciable mais la
médaille à son revers je dirais même que
fâcheusement on se rapproche un peu de
la politique du carnet tchèque c'est
quelque chose qui profita tous mais la
difficulté que cela avantage les initiés
c'est à dire ceux qui savent déjà ce
qu'ils vont faire le jeune qui aime les
livres qui aime les musées c'est de
quelle manière il va utiliser le Pass
mais celui qui n'a pas d'idée ne sera
comment recourir à cette aide c'est donc
plus une démarche confirmatrice que
créatrice de démarche culturelle et du
point de vue de l'éducation artistique
on ne peut que déplorer une baisse des
fonds et ainsi une démarche qu'on
construites avec l'Éducation nationale
plutôt qu'au des fonds qui
s'additionnent me paraît plus judicieuse
je souhaite bien sûr attirer l'attention
sur les festivals ils ont bien résisté
malgré deux années rudes comme les
acteurs de ce secteur l'ont indiqué ils
ont été les premiers à fermer et les
derniers à ouvrir au bout de ces deux
années les publics sont globalement
restés fidèles au rendez-vous et c'est
heureux même si nous déplorons la
disparition de certains festivals est
restée abondante mais pour combien de
temps encore
à peine est-on sorti de cette crise que
de nouvelles difficultés pointent leur
nez avec un heureux événement
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 sans pour autant
opposer le sport à la culture et sont
créés bien sûr de rivalité entre les
événements nos grêtons un manque de
visibilité et une absence de dialogue
entre tous les partenaires concernés les
festivals sont tributaires d'Alea et
leur répétition de toutes sortes
interroge il a été envisagé de réfléchir
un système d'assurance qui prendrait non
seulement les risques artistiques mais
aussi climatiques peut-être est une
piste à explorer je n'ose pas le risque
à la protection mais comment se lancer
durablement si les perspectives sont
sombres sans cette assurance et cela
vaut dans tous les sens du terme le
risque est tout simplement que les
festivals fassent les frais de la loi du
marché qu'en est-il des bénévoles de
l'engagement des collectivités
territoriales avec ce manque de
visibilité et de perspective
un festival se prépare au minimum deux
ans à l'avance soutenons nos festivals
qui ne doivent pas faire les frais de
ces nouvelles contraintes nous
regrettons toujours l'absence de
référents festival tant au niveau
national que régional alors que c'est un
sujet brûlant pour l'orientation des
politiques culturelles et la défense de
l'accès à la culture sur tout le
territoire quelle place voulons-nous
donner à la culture dans notre société
soyons ambitieux et inventifs nous
voterons les crédits de la mission
culture malgré certaines insuffisances
et de nombreuses réserves nous comptons
sur vous pour gagner ces arbitrages
nécessaires
merci
madame la ministre c'est à vous
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission Charleroi
Lafont messieurs les rapporteurs
spéciaux chez Vincent et blé dédié Rambo
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
pour avis mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'avais mon masque je l'ai
enlevé sous je viens d'avoir mon
résultat de tester négatif juste pour
vous expliquer et que vous n'ayez pas
d'inquiétude
[Rires]
hormis cette bonne nouvelle je suis très
heureuse d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
pour la vraie bonne nouvelle de la
journée ce budget du ministère de la
Culture que nous allons étudier pour la
première partie la mission culture qui
est en hausse assez historique je
voudrais
avant de commencer ma présentation
vraiment vous remercier pour tous les
échanges constructifs et très précis que
nous avons eu au fil des derniers mois
que ce soit en commission ou lors des
rendez-vous bilatéraux que nous avons pu
avoir ce sont à chaque fois des moments
très utiles et je salue aussi la qualité
de vos rapports qui sont des sources
d'inspiration pour nos travaux au
quotidien vous l'avez tous dit le monde
de la culture vient de traverser
deux ans de pandémie
dont on ressent encore les effets
aujourd'hui mais il reste plus résilient
plus fort que dans de nombreux pays y
compris de nos voisins européens grâce à
toutes les aides qui ont pu être
déployées par l'État pendant la crise
grâce aussi à cette capacité
d'innovation permanente et de lien avec
les publics que les lieux culturels
l'ensemble de l'écosystème de la Culture
a pu porter et maintenir
mais bien avant cette crise sanitaire
une autre révolution est venue impacter
le monde de la culture depuis même 10 20
un peu plus que ça au moins 20 ans c'est
la révolution numérique qui est à la
fois porteuse d'opportunités mais aussi
de menaces pour la création pour les
auteurs pour les créateurs
la crise sanitaire au fond est venue
accélérer ses mutations qui étaient déjà
en germe notamment elle a amplifié la
puissance des géants du numérique et à
la souligné les inégalités sociales de
l'accès à la culture
nous si nous regardons les études
décennales du ministère de la culture
c'est un outil très précieux pour voir
les évolutions structuelles cette étude
sur les pratiques culturelles des
Français a montré en réalité une
fracture générationnelle qui se creuse
certes accélérée par la pandémie mais
présente bien avant qu'on pourrait
résumer ainsi aux plus âgé une culture
de sortie vers les musées les spectacles
etc et au plus jeunes une culture qu'on
pourrait qualifier de salon avec cette
addiction aux écrans qui se développent
mais qui ne se limite pas qu'à la
jeunesse c'est vraiment aujourd'hui à
toute la population qu'on doit donner et
redonner envie de culture en chair et en
os
c'est l'ambition en tout cas que je
porte au ministère de la Culture et
c'est pour ça que ce budget et
historiquement haut puisque il est
aujourd'hui à 3,7 milliards d'euros de
crédit pour la mission culture soit 7,4
% de plus que l'année passée vous le
savez au-delà des crédits de la mission
culture on y reviendra plus tard dans la
journée puisque nous allons étudier les
crédits de la mission média livre et
industrie culturels qui eux s'élèvent à
704 millions d'euros plus
3,8 milliards d'euros consacrés à
l'audiovisuel public j'ajoute à cela
769 millions d'euros de taxes affectées
et près de 2 milliards d'euros de
dépenses fiscales j'ai bien entendu vos
inquiétudes faire leurs Archos au sujet
de la pérennité de certains crédits
d'impôts vous savez qu'aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement est de
permettre une évaluation la plus précise
possible avant de pouvoir en rediscuter
mais nous serons très vigilants
au total si j'additionne toutes ces
enveloppes ce sont 11 milliards d'euros
de financement dont le ministère de la
Culture à la responsabilité et qui
permettent d'injecter toute l'ambition
que nous voulons porter pour la
politique culturelle de ce pays le
budget que je vous présente ce vœu
réellement un budget de résilience et
d'action résilience que vous l'avez tous
dit nous sommes encore en convalescence
post pandémie et nous devons accompagner
l'ensemble des secteurs culturels pour
faire face à ces défis dans ces défis du
présent il y a également la crise
énergétique vous l'avez largement
mentionné c'est une priorité de ce
budget avec 56 millions d'euros
débloqués pour répondre aux besoins aux
besoins immédiats du contexte
énergétique que nous connaissons mais
c'est aussi un budget d'action pour
préparer l'avenir et si je reste sur cet
exemple de la sobriété énergétique et de
cette priorité pour la transition
écologique ce budget permet d'investir à
plus long terme pour des travaux
assez significatif dans cette
perspective d'une meilleure isolation
thermique des bâtiments et d'une
amélioration des performances
énergétiques des bâtiments culturels
c'est pour ça que le budget
d'investissement de la mission culture
s'élève en 2023 à 627 millions d'euros
en augmentation de 70 millions avec
notamment des exemples que certains
d'entre vous ont cité par exemple les
travaux du musée d'Orsay du 4 National
de Chaillot je pourrais citer aussi
l'école d'architecture de Limoges ou
celle de Lille tous ces travaux se sont
que quelques exemples vise à améliorer
la performance énergétique des bâtiments
donc a baissé à terme leur facture
d'énergie et à engager cette énorme
chantier de décarbonation de la culture
que j'ai placé au cœur de mes priorités
des carbonation de la culture et
conciliation je vous rejoins totalement
sur cette nécessité de concilier le
patrimoine ça préservation ça
valorisation et le développement des
énergies renouvelables nous sommes en ce
moment en train de travailler sur une
ins par exemple pour l'intégration des
panneaux photovoltaïques dans une
démarche respectueuse de la préservation
du patrimoine c'est tout à fait possible
de concilier les deux
ce budget pour ne pas être trop longue
je voulais vous le présenter autour de
quelques grandes priorités qui me
tiennent à cœur j'en ai choisi 5
l'éducation artistique la souveraineté
le patrimoine l'emploi et
l'international
concernant l'éducation artistique je
vous remercie tous d'en avoir parlé car
nous sommes réunis je pense ici par cet
enjeu crucial qui est de sensibiliser
dès le plus jeune âge les jeunes
générations à toutes les possibilités
d'émancipation et de développement
d'esprit critique et de confiance en soi
que permet la culture dans le budget
2023 ce sont 14 millions supplémentaires
qui sont dédiés à cette priorité avec 4
millions pour l'éducation artistique or
passe culture et 9,5% 9 et demi 9,5
millions pardonnez-moi pour le Pass
Culture vous en avez largement parlé je
voudrais insister sur le fait que se
passe culture est un nouveau passe
culture depuis quelques mois c'est un
pass Culture collectif plus participatif
avec cette dimension de passe culture
pour les classes au collège avec 25
euros par élève pour chaque enseignant
on peut voir à ce titre d'ailleurs que
ce qui arrive en premier dans les
sorties scolaires des tous les chiffres
qui nous remontent c'est bien le
spectacle vivant le théâtre qui avait
plus de mal à arriver en tête pour le
Pass Culture individuel et nous avons
aujourd'hui 2,2 millions de jeunes
inscrits pour le Pass Culture individuel
la part personnelle du Pass Culture ce
qui est colossal et vraiment j'insiste
sur le fait cher Didier Rambaud que ça
n'est pas une plateforme d'achat je vous
rejoins sur cette ambition là c'est un
outil aussi pour faire participer les
jeunes pour les engager en faire des
protagonistes pas uniquement des
consommateurs chers aussi monsieur
ouzouglas vous le savez à l'époque de
Malraux Internet et les smartphones
n'existaient pas donc évidemment que le
l'enjeu de la médiation il est au cœur
de nos politiques mais aujourd'hui vous
avez vous-même démontré à quel point le
Pass Culture répond en fait à ce nouvel
usage que tous les jeunes ont un
smartphone d'ailleurs nous aussi les
adultes et nous voyons bien cette
addiction à ces machines et que c'est
via ces machines aussi que nous devons
les toucher mais le Pass Culture a
développé des parcours un cercle
d'ambassadeurs des des expériences qui
permettent d'aller bien au-delà du
simple acte d'achat du clic d'achat je
pourrais revenir dans les réponses au
salon si vous le souhaitez je voudrais
aussi vous signaler que ce pas sculpture
devient de plus en plus européen et
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
l'Espagne j'ai été au mois de septembre
à lancer son bonus couple tourin et
l'Allemagne j'ai été il y a trois jours
à également décidé de mettre en place un
passe sculpture un cool tour passe qui
est complètement calqué l'affirme comme
tel sur le Pass culture française ça
veut bien dire que plus nous serons
nombreux à le porter plus les jeunes
européens seront reliés aussi par cette
nouvelle ambition culturelle
deuxième priorité qui me tient à coeur
et dont je voulais vous parler c'est
celle de la souveraineté culturelle
souveraineté que je vois à la fois dans
le monde physique pour soutenir la
création soutenir les métiers d'art
soutenir la langue française soutenir la
création avec le programme mon nouveau
mais que je vois aussi dans le monde
numérique et c'est vrai que le plan
France 2030 hors de ce budget et là
aussi pour nous aider à investir sur des
studios de tournage sur des formations
nouvelles sur des expériences immersives
en lien aussi avec les expériences
physiques et sur ce que sera plus tard
le métaver mais dans une approche
française une approche sensorielle une
approche aussi qui défend la liberté
d'expression et de création j'y tiens
beaucoup
merci en tout cas chère Julien barjoton
d'avoir insisté sur le plan métier d'Arc
qui me tient très à coeur et dont on
voit une amorce dans ce budget 2023 avec
une augmentation du soutien au
manufactures nationales c'est vrai le
Mobilier national qui sont un peu les
fleurons de nos manufactures pour
pouvoir porter une partie de ce nouveau
plan pour les métiers d'art sur lequel
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir
je voulais insister également sur
l'enjeu de la langue française et
dans ce budget vous avez vu qu'il y a
une légère hausse pour accompagner en
plus de l'important investissement
en travaux le l'ouverture au printemps
2023 de la Cité internationale de la
langue française à Villers-Cotterêts j'y
étais samedi pour faire le point sur le
chantier et changer avec les élus c'est
un projet qui avance très bien et merci
Monsieur Brisson de redire tout votre
attachement à ce projet je voulais juste
vous préciser que dès le 17 mars 2017
le président de la République qui
étaient candidat à l'époque Emmanuel
Macron avait fait un discours à Reims où
il avait déjà dit que le projet serait
un projet dédié à la langue française
donc ça n'est pas venu après ça a été
d'abord une intuition forte de sauver ce
château et de le sauver pour un projet
dédié à la langue française étant donné
aussi l'histoire de cette ville de
naissance d'Alexandre Dumas et de ce
château où a eu lieu l'ordonnance de
Villers-Cotterêts
le temps file je voudrais vous parler
également de l'importance du patrimoine
dans ce budget qui atteint un budget
historique de plus d'un milliard d'euros
avec vous l'avez tous dit l'enjeu des
cathédrales leur sécurisation leur
restauration le soutien monument
historique dans tous les territoires des
crédits pour des projets emblématiques
en région comme la reconversion de
l'ancienne abbaye de Clairvaux avec 15
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement chers Vanina paoligajin un
effort aussi pour les dispositifs qui
accompagne les collectivités
territoriales le fameux FIP le fond
incitatif pour le patrimoine qui en
augmentation ou encore la hausse aussi
des fouilles programmées et des
diagnostics archéologiques auxquels nous
sommes tous très attachés
quatrième priorité l'emploi les
compétences ce budget j'ai voulu
vraiment m'attacher à ce que il puisse
permettre de d'accompagner les futurs
talents et de
structurer mieux notre politique
d'accompagnement à l'emploi avec une
priorité majeure qui est celle des
écoles les établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs artistique et
parmi elles les écoles d'architecture
c'est quand même un vivier de 20 000
étudiants un vivier extraordinaire qui
seront les bâtisseurs de demain les
penseurs des villes et des logements de
demain donc il y a un effort très
particulier pour les écoles
d'architecture dans ce budget je ne
reviens pas vous l'avez mentionné les
bourses les hausses des travaux de mise
au normes les crédits supplémentaires
aussi pour hors école l'emploi
artistique les artistes auteurs je ne
détaille pas tout ce que vous avez déjà
dit les moyens du ministère sont eux
aussi confortés la masse salariale va
augmenter de 38 millions d'euros pour
atteindre 532 millions d'euros
avec les pays où des artistes sont
menacés pour créer son menacées dans
leur liberté d'expression ont été
contraints de fuir suite à la guerre je
pense à l'Ukraine je pense à
l'Afghanistan je pense à l'Iran et à
tant d'autres pays
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les quelques priorités de la
mission culture de ce projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 sur lesquels je
voulais insister c'est un budget
ambitieux je l'ai dit en forte hausse
qui nous permettra de répondre aux
grands défis du présent mais aussi de
l'avenir de continuer à porter une voix
forte dans le monde 15 minutes c'est
court pour partager avec vous toutes mes
convictions toutes mes priorités mais
avant de passer à l'examen des
amendements je voulais vous adresser un
dernier message par le biais d'un poème
c'est devenu notre rituel un poème de
Jean-Pierre Siméon
je cherche un mot vaste et chaud comme
une chambre sonore comme une harpe
dansant comme une robe claire comme un
avril un mot que rien n'est fasse comme
une empreinte dans l'écorce un mot que
le mensonge ne séduit pas un mot pour
tout dire la mort la ville la peur le
silence et la plainte l'invisible et le
doux et les miracles de l'été depuis si
longtemps je cherche mais j'ai confiance
en vous il va naître de vos lèvres merci
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues je vais sur des
suspendre la séance pour quelques
minutes elles sont à reprise à 17h15
[Musique]